talk to me about uh bing bong and like
how the knicks remix came to be and
the bing bong stuff is um
you're a knicks fan obviously despite
being from brooklyn you you weren't one
of these people who jumped ship to the
nets because a lot there's a lot of
those yeah i'm a lifelong knicks fan but
i'm also if if the nets go to the
playoffs i'm rooting for them because
i'm brooklyn all the way even though
they're really the jerseys
listen they're brooklyn now they got
brooklyn in their name if they win i'm
gonna root for them of course um
but i'm a knicks fan and uh
the knicks been [ __ ] forever for the
longest yeah so if i could if i created
something that's making this them get
hyped and maybe possibly put the battery
in their back to win some games i love
it but i just started off saying it like
messing around bing bong you know like
yeah you know you say yo you know i just
body this verse bomb you know and then i
just bing bong just playing around i
would throw it on my stories on
instagram bing bong showing my merch and
then it just took off i started putting
on t's and hats and started selling and
um
and then i started the side talk people
the side talk kids that's the popular
instagram page popping they would have
me in their video they'd come to coney
island i'm saying it bing bong bing bong
and then just took off from there and
then the knicks
just took off with it and it just was
like was there a certain player that
like [ __ ] nah what happened is that
um they was in front of the knicks
opening night and the knicks had one
everybody in this oh they were losing
their [ __ ] minds yeah they're all
crazy
from seeing me saying it all the time
and uh and the next just ran with it
took it all the knicks fans just ran
with it and then now i'm starting i'm
doing all types of sports talk radios
all type of crap carton and robbers
they're showing me love they're bringing
me up there and i'm like yo this is a
whole new
fan base in general just right now in
the airport come here at least three to
four guys that i know don't even listen
to rap right right came up to me and yo
you're the bing bong guy and last night
at the show somebody's kid was he was
like yo my son their basketball team is
loves the bing book you sent me a video
of my my kill no problem man
yeah
i spent years doing
um
bringing negativity into the world you
know doing the wrong thing growing up i
did jail time i was doing robberies
right do all types of stuff so it's a
good chance to switch it up man and
bring some positive stuff into the into
the atmosphere now